hey guys i don't know if you saw these
two stories uh both out of new york
having to do with the copic craziness
this week first there's a restaurant
owner who got a ticket
apparently for leaving his door open uh
during business hours he didn't have any
customers eating inside god forbid
nothing like that he just had the door
open why is that against the law why
can't you do that well i guess because
if he had covid
right he might cough or something eject
it from his mouth
the virus particles would travel across
the restaurant
out the door down the street and infect
some unsuspecting pedestrian could
happen you never know well it really
couldn't happen but but even so
meanwhile another restaurant in new york
has diners outside
in bubbles literal plastic bubbles we
have become actual bubble boys now
and they are eating in bubbles because
of coven what's that gonna achieve
you're putting people
in tightly enclosed spaces uh talking to
each other for extended periods of time
how does that how does that help and
then what happens to the waiter who has
to
enter the germ bubble to take the order
and what happens to the next group
that gets to that that has to reuse the
same bubble what you spray a little
lysol in there you think that's going to
achieve something
why not just let people eat inside if
that's what you're going to do
well there's no reason not to but this
has been the theme this is what you see
right when you look around both with
government policy and what individual
companies and industries are deciding to
do on their own
so much of it is arbitrary ineffectual
downright counterproductive
think about the airlines that demand
that you you keep social distance
stay six feet apart as you're boarding
the airplane
and then they turn around and stick you
in a metal tube with the same people for
six hours
what's the point of spacing everybody
out before crunching them together again
like an accordion sort of thing what's
what's the point of that
again arbitrary pointless why
because the attitude is and this is
always the attitude
whenever whenever we're scared of
something it's always well just do
something
do something we have to do something do
anything it doesn't matter what we do as
long as you're doing something
and it's kind of like what happens after
a mass shooting right we've seen this
over and over again
mass shooting happens and politicians
they want to pass a law they want to
pass a regulation they want to do
something
do anything in response to the event and
they'll brag about it they'll say we did
something we did something
okay but what you did didn't help it
probably made the situation worse
that you did something probably would
have been better if you did nothing in
that case
so this do something do anything
attitude is
is destroying this country has been for
a while and is especially now because
people don't want to admit
that often there's not a lot you can do
bad things happen uh there are threats
out there there are dangers there are
risks
you want to go out to eat i think it's a
great idea i've been out to eat with my
family many times
in recent months and there's there's
going to be a small amount of risk
there's a small amount of risk
that comes from many different
directions anytime you leave your house
covet or no covet
you have to be willing to accept that uh
putting yourself in a bubble
that's that's not gonna help much it's
just gonna make it worse so
in general in life we take reasonable
precautions
tailored to the circumstance but you
live your life
and i think that's what we all really
need to start doing just just
just live your life that's it